une tour de 12 mètres de haut avec un
mécanisme de bras articulés sur le toit
construite en 1809 elle a été totalement
restauré il y a vingt ans inventé en
1793 le télégraphe optique permettait de
relayer des messages sur de grandes
distances en un temps record 8 heures au
lieu de 8 jours par exemple pour un
message est à cheval entre paris et
toulon pierre bouchon est le sauveur de
la tour chappe dan où il a été le
premier à s'intéresser à ce qu'il reste
de la ligne qui traverse et son
département
il y avait dix tours dans l'yonne sur la
ligne paris lyon 1 qui commençait à la
hauteur du loiret jusqu'à la côte d'or
et c'est la seule qui était debout qui
ressemblait encore à un bâtiment toutes
les autres avaient été barrés et boules
et les cailloux été enlevée défricher au
milieu des champs est-ce qu'il a protégé
ses son emplacement milieu des bois bien
sûr à l'époque les bois n'existait pas
la visibilité était indispensable au
fonctionnement du télégraphe optique
inventé par claude chappe avec une
longue-vue à une distance de 10 km on
pouvait voir la position des bras
articulés au sommet des édifices
vous avez une grande barre là qui fait
environ quatre mètres de long dans la
réalité
c'est ce qu'on appelle un régulateur il
tourne comme une hélice d'avion et à
chacune de ses extrémités
vous avez un indicateur qui lui tourne
comme une aiguille dans l'oeuf faut
baisser la tête pour pas se cogner parce
que le passage est assez étroit et on
arrive à laitages où il ya le système
pour manipuler donc ici les deux
stationnaire était ici en permanence et
regardait par les lunettes les tours
voisines qui ne savait pas à quelle
heure les messages à l'arrivée techint
stationner envoyé une tour qui
commençait à bouger
d'un côté ou de l'autre il l'appelait
son camarade qui se mettaient façon
manipulateur
et celui qui regardaient dans la lunette
lui indiquaient les signaux qu'il était
transmis grâce à ce qu'on appelle un
répétiteur comme celui ci qui permettait
d'indiquer le signal transmis par
exemple on va dire celui ci les
stationnaire ne connaissait pas la
signification des signaux qu'il
transmettait car le telegraph était
réservé au gouvernement au préfet et à
l'armée
seuls habilités au décryptage du code
secret composé de deux signaux la
verticale correspondant à un numéro de
page
l'autre horizontale renvoyant à un
numéro de ligne dans un livre appelé le
vocabulaire où étaient inscrits des mots
ou des bouts de phrases
ici nous avons un exemple de dépêches à
la page 80 lignes 52 les termes inscrits
sont le secrétaire des conseils aux
autorités civiles et militaires
de la même façon le mot troupe est
inscrit à la page 89 ligne 16 du même
vocabulaire le télégraphe chappe est
tombé en désuétude après 1850
remplacé par le télégraphe électrique la
tour d'anne ou est ouverte à la visite
les après midi des premiers dimanches de
chaque mois de mai à septembre